La huge announcement I am shooting my
special Wednesday December 14th here in
Los Angeles at the dynasty typewriter
theater go to ryansickler.com for
tickets use code sickler you're gonna
get half off tickets all right please
come out I want the place packed we're
doing two shows and uh I want all the
die hards there all right screw the
industry this is for the fans go to
ryancicler.com get your tickets today
Chicago thank you so much for your
support another great weekend you guys
are the [ __ ] best Grand Rapids I'll
see you all December 9th and 10th get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows on my website at ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I'm gonna start this
episode like I start almost all of them
and I want to say thank you for your
support thank you for watching if you
are watching just hit that subscribe
button it means everything to us it's a
huge help and it's free it doesn't cost
you a damn dime but you know it's not
free the patreon if you gotta have more
then you gotta subscribe to the patreon
there's only one level it's five bucks a
month there's not a bunch of tears and
all this [ __ ] it's five bucks a
month it's called the Honeydew with
y'all and I highlight the low lights
with you all and you all have the
wildest [ __ ] stories I've ever heard
in my life it's a show I can't stop
talking about when I talk to my friends
I'm like you should hear this one about
the guy that solved an 18 year old Cold
Case you should hear one about the chick
with the two [ __ ] it's all on there
it's five bucks a month if you sign up
for a year you're getting over a month
free and you get 100 do a day early you
get it ad free and you get it at no
additional cost all right if I am in
your city when you're around come on out
and see me on tour tickets are available
at ryansickler.com Chicago November 11th
and 12th Grand Rapids I'll be there
December 9th and 10th all right that's
the biz you guys know what we're doing
over here we highlight the low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I am very excited to have
this guest on today first time here on
the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Jim Florentine welcome to the
Honeydew gym thanks for having me man I
appreciate it thank you for having me
thank you for being here yeah man
absolutely we did an old crab Feast that
I still talk about and I haven't seen
you probably since
it's been years up I remember it was
like I said it's three years since you
even been out here yeah right so I think
it was you like your kitchen table or
something and you're like five or six
years yeah yeah dude
um well welcome please before we get
into anything plug and promote
everything you want to get out there my
new comedy special bite the bullets on
Amazon Prime you can rent to buy it
there I got a new prank call CD called
terrorizing telemarketers volume seven
seven volume seven I've been doing it
for 20 years I haven't grown up still
making prank calls that's out it was
recently number one on the comedy charts
was awesome so wherever you listen to
music get that and I do a podcast called
everybody is awful it's out every Monday
and they'll be in Dallas Fort Worth
Texas November 4th and fifth hyenas
Comedy Club I'll be at the Key West
Comedy Club in Key West Florida November
17th through the 20th and Detroit
December 10th through the 12th at the
House of Comedy oh what the heck is
going to say that's newer right it just
opened it yeah new club yeah cause I'm
wondering what the people hit me up all
the time about why don't you come to
Detroit and I'm like is there even a
comedy seen in Detroit I don't know I
don't know either I haven't done I've
done a couple of rock clubs there so
this is this club just opened so all
right you know so yeah that's it
um well we're going to talk about
something that's going to be heavy I'm
going to tell people that at the at the
top now because some people get upset
that I don't give trigger warnings I'm
outside like I don't know what the [ __ ]
everybody's gonna say all the time but
you uh want to talk about a suicide yeah
can we talk about it of course yeah I am
um tell me everything
had a girlfriend you know uh well first
of all I grew up uh Catholic so you know
my mom's side's not a thing it's not a
thing but also you know I come from a
family of seven kids my mom basically
was always like trying to save people
that was a thing she was super religious
she could have been like the next Mother
Teresa she would just take people in off
the street anybody let's take care of
them so that's all I knew so when I said
you got to take care of people you gotta
have empathy if they're damaged you know
try to fix them basically and how old
are you at the time you're dating this
this girl yeah mid-30s okay so I I I I
meet this girl she was in a lot of
trouble like you know craziness you know
just some shady [ __ ] going on in her
life and you know she's like can I stay
with you for a little bit I'm like yeah
sure and then basically she never left
adopted foster homes molested just a
horrible horrible childhood awful I felt
bad for her so I'm like I can't you know
she didn't have anybody to go to no
family no nothing so I'm like yeah stay
with me we became Brooke boyfriend and
girlfriend together for six years oh wow
okay yeah we're six years and you know I
just like I knew she needed she didn't
have anybody else so I'm like she's just
she really had nobody else nobody else I
mean he adopted family he kind of like
turned on her she you know she didn't
know who her real parents were and all
that stuff but you had you know
depression issues and all that I knew
that going in you know when you think
you could you could solve that you think
okay I could fix this somehow how old
was she she was I was 35 she was
probably like 25 26 somewhere around
there so I mean really young yeah just
like a little girl you know what I mean
I just I really felt I just felt bad and
you're raised to to not turn your back
on people don't turn your back and my
mom and my whole family took her in
because nobody yeah oh yeah they loved
her yeah okay so your mom sort of gave
her a support system and all that of
course and she was like wow I really I
finally have a family okay and I was
like well how can I and I knew it wasn't
ultimate to write you know relationship
but I was like what am I gonna do I
Gotta Throw This girl out on the street
you know what I mean she finally feels
like she's part of a family and now let
me ask you what because I'm sure that
Guild's playing on YouTube but why did
you know it wasn't the right
relationship because you know just uh
the you know whether it was bipolar or
depression issues up and down highs and
lows it's crazy sustainable it wasn't
sustainable and I like you know I I'm
I'm a low-key mellow guy I don't need
that craziness in my life hey [ __ ]
man and then all of a sudden it comes
down at me yeah yeah exactly I'm just
you know yeah I don't want any part of
that and it was like it was you know so
I'm like man this is was she on meds or
anything like that off and on here and
there you know
and um
you know got to the point maybe I don't
know a year four or five she was like
you know she always mentioned you know I
wish I could just go to sleep and never
wake up but you would oh yeah but you
know I you know when you don't know
anything about suicide it's almost like
you think they're just it's a cry for
help like oh they're just saying I wish
I could I would just kill myself and
then I get I don't have to worry about
anything and you're like come on you
know what everybody loves you that's why
would you say that people care about you
but they don't want to hear that and
that's actually a sign when people
actually start talking about it you
think they're just looking for attention
but that means they're really thinking
about that right
okay I had no clue this is something
they should teach everybody you know a
friend or whatever like that because you
think oh see they need attention again
what is it now you know whatever like
but meanwhile they're really hurting
inside
so I got to the point about year five I
said listen I gotta I gotta her adopted
family basically disowned her she hated
them anyway they tortured her growing up
whatever so I said I gotta isn't that
[ __ ] crazy I don't mean interrupting
to adopt a child and then to treat him
like [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] that makes
no sense it was like this menendeed uh
Amish like he was the pastor so they
adopted all these kids these black and
Asian all these different color kids to
go hey look at us we're in the community
look we adopted all these kids and
meanwhile a complete nightmare you see
those documentaries on Netflix I just
watched that Mormon one uh right yeah
yeah so they they go oh they're a pillar
of community look what they did they
brought all these people together
already they're not just white kids and
they're looking they got you know oh
yeah they're great and meanwhile it's
just you know what's going on the way
they're raising them and [ __ ] like that
so it really messed with her
so I was like I gotta find your real mom
because me because I know okay I said
because I go maybe she can you know
develop a relationship with her and then
maybe I can hand her off to her
and you know she could live a good life
now do you tell her you're looking for
her real mom and she didn't want me to
she goes what if she rejects me again
then what do I do that's got to be tough
I mean that got to come from a loving
family but if my mom if I got you know
put up for adoption I try to find my
real mom and I find her and she rejects
me again that's got to be devastating I
want you in the first place I didn't
want you in the first place
so I said real quick your dad was he
around yeah he was uh he wasn't around
at this point my parents were married 33
years he passed away probably five years
before that all right well he was just
as all in on bringing people in and
helping them and stuff like that yeah
your mom pretty much yeah well yeah he's
like man I gotta buy more [ __ ]
groceries
people living here you got to be kidding
me
oh yeah he's like [ __ ] yeah and this is
before Costco and BJ's where you could
buy bulk [ __ ] he's like yeah how many
toilets did you have in your house
one three all right that's good that's
good yeah it was a two and a half yeah I
was gonna say for seven of you had to at
least have no wait it was me and my two
older brothers in a bunk bed and we had
a bed like you know on the floor
basically like a cot so that was our
room
and then the girls had their own room
two of them one of them had it so it was
you know yeah but it was cool it was we
grew up in a great community and a lot
of friends all that stuff so you know
but yeah he was just like God damn all
these people they're sleeping on the
couches this and that my mom's like give
up your bunk I'm like I'm not giving up
my bunk come on what else I gotta do so
um so we ultimately find I open
ultimately find them yeah how'd you do
that
um
the adopted mom still had a contact
what's [ __ ] crazy is adopted mom
would tell because she's like adorned
her childhood and growing up she's like
I want to meet my real mom I want to see
if she has any health conditions maybe
yeah [ __ ] and she's like your real mom
doesn't want to see you she doesn't say
yeah oh yeah man [ __ ] crazy but she
had a contact from a pastor who gave her
away or whatever like that and you were
in touch with the adopted family we'd
see him once in a while you know he'd
feel attention we try to like and she's
like I hate him I go let's just hang
with them whatever so she knew that she
had that piece of paper with that
contact on it but she would make up
these stories your mother doesn't want
to see you she hates you your mother's a
prostitute she's uh she had a crash she
had a crack baby she was living on the
street and she's like oh man like you
know and I went to adopt him I go look I
need that number she's like no and I'm
like I gotta I want to find a real mom
she was I'm not giving it to you I'm
like listen you better [ __ ] give me
that
because she was trying to cover up all
these lies
we ultimately found their mom none of
that happened she wasn't crack babies
wasn't addicted to drugs what was she
she was a normal woman living in Orange
County that what just had a young chief
he came over and she was Vietnamese she
came over during the war and the father
stayed back or whatever and she came
with the baby and she couldn't she
didn't know what to do she couldn't
speak English the church goes here give
her up the church where my you know the
uh adopted Place goes give her up we'll
take care of the baby you can see or
whatever so she gave the baby up she
didn't know what she had to go to work
so you find this woman and she's living
in Orange County we're talking about uh
New York Orange County no I know Orange
County Oh California yeah yeah no [ __ ]
okay so she's out here yeah and then
what do you fly out the meter you fly
out to meet her is and is your
girlfriend can we is it okay to mention
her name yeah Jade okay so Jade is she
like I don't want to do this or is she
then like holy [ __ ] you found her I'm
all in
she was on the fence she wanted to but
then she was like I said afraid that she
was gonna get rejected from her and how
was the mom when you talked to her was
she excited about meeting her daughter
super excited she was we talked to her
on the phone it's like oh my God you
have a brother you have a sister he's
got all his cousins they all lived in
that little Community dude so it aren't
the whole family oh and they were all
there they were all there you know that
little Community there so they were all
living there
so we fly in LAX we go we drive out
there we meet him she meets everybody it
was unbelievable yeah what's that like
they were just there was like 30 of them
like were you emotional watching that
yeah
because I come from a good family and I
know you know and it's just like she
finally it was you know they were
waiting for us we pulled in the driver
hell yeah 25 of us I got chills I know
man it was unbelievable that's cool yeah
so we hang we're talking this one she's
showing pictures this is when you were a
baby I saw she never saw those baby
pictures you know and then I take the
stepdad aside when this all going on I
go Hey listen this is what the adopting
mom said that you know she was a crack
baby she was drug addict living on the
streets like she's been working for like
you know some local company for 25 years
you know whatever so all that was lies
the adopted mother didn't want her to
meet the real mom she because the
adopted them I was like controlling so
hey I'm not gonna let you beat your real
mom because then you might leave me and
right and I raised you right so
um do we go out to dinner we had a big
connection like two months later they
come to the east coast in New Jersey
spend Christmas with us Jose who comes
her mom her real mom the stepdad and a
couple of her cousins and sisters holy
[ __ ] they all came your dad's like how
many of them are fun no my dad my dad
wasn't around my dad was around oh yeah
he would have been like you got to be
fine he'd be like 12 more well no now
they stayed at my place now I gotta feed
him I'm like [ __ ] it's your turn yeah
yeah and then I want to go to Chipotle
either you know what I mean I'm living
outside of New York City they're like
come on we want to go I'm like [ __ ] this
is killing me and then I gotta pay for
him my girl's like come on don't make
them pay they don't have a lot of money
I find so I'm taking these nice
restaurants or whatever so they spend
Christmas with us
you know and then they you know had a
good relationship we come out a lot
visit them she'd come to see him
whatever like that I'm like all right
good she's in good hands now she has
some support system around there
But ultimately that didn't work either
how long did that about a year year and
a half okay a year year and a half and
did she ever meet her real father no the
real father stayed back maybe like Japan
or something yeah so she never met him
so that didn't help huh It ultimately
didn't help so what happens what do you
see happen over like are they visiting
each other back and forth for a little
while they're visiting they're talking
on the phone all this other stuff but
you know
um
you know just you know with that with
depression you don't know you don't know
and you know when someone's suicidal it
could start she always said she goes I
would say in grade school I want to kill
myself I'm like who would say that in
grade school you know she goes on the
seventh eighth grade I always think that
you know so it was always there I just
thought this was really gonna help it
and she was doing really well she had
the connection but then
you know ultimately it she you know just
to highs and lows I remember her Talent
she told her sister
that I'm thinking about killing myself
and her sister called me because I I
didn't even see it I thought she was in
a good goodness because her sister who
she's just met over the last year yeah
so she calls me she goes you better
check on her she told me this and I went
through I go did you say that she goes
well I was just having a bad moment I go
what do you mean you know I couldn't
understand I'm like thought everything
was good I don't know I'm still a
[ __ ] idiot when it comes to this I'm
thinking everything's solved the problem
solved you know as a guy you just want
to fix it right it's fixed right oh
let's move on yeah
and then uh you know one night um she
just um she was gonna go to a show with
me I was hoping for dice at the time
it's like a local show and she's like I
go you want to go she goes no I'm not
feeling that well I'm just gonna stay
home like all right I mean
she goes can you take it we had a little
dog show should you take your dog to my
mom's house my mom was like on the way
and I'm like why she goes I'm just not
feeling like oh you know so the dog's
not gonna bother you the dog's just
gonna lay with you she goes you can't
take her I know it's kind of out of the
way I go I don't want to do that I gotta
pick her up on the way back all right
fine
so then you know I'm the middle of doing
this so ultimately what my girl did as
soon as I left she drove to my mom's
house like 45 minutes away and dropped
the dog off she did yeah
and my mom's like what's going on she
goes oh Jim said to drop the dog off
he's gonna pick a later my mom's like
okay I don't know why all right no
problem because my mom will watch the
dog wear away
she didn't want the dog there when she
did it
I think you know she was like the dog's
gonna you know so she didn't I don't
know I don't know what was going through
her mind at the time all I know is I'm
on stage at this theater
and in the middle of my show I I feel
it's like jolt go through me nah I swear
to God I'm like I I almost I felt like I
got electrocuted like halfway through
the set I'm like what the hell was that
I thought it was from the stage some you
know shock or something like that and
then when I get off stage she left a
voicemail
on my phone just like I gotta be out of
pain I'm sorry I'm doing this but no way
yeah please don't you know forgive me go
on live your life whatever I'm really
sorry just know it's not you it's me
you walk off stage and grab your phone
and she never calls like a white because
I saw a voicemail from her I'm like why
is she called she knows I'm working like
we just talk when we get home maybe she
would text me but I see a voicemail I'm
like that's weird I didn't listen to her
right away either because I was like all
right I was talking after the show I had
the adrenaline going or whatever in
about 15-20 minutes later okay let me
see what you what what you wanted and I
hear this
so you know I uh and how far away are
you from home where this venue is 30
minutes [ __ ] yeah and then I call my mom
and she goes well she dropped the dog
off and I was like you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me
that is that when you like that's what
it's yeah because she's done this before
she goes you know and I'm like stop I'll
be home in a little while like just not
not like that but she's just like I'm
having a bad moment I don't know I'm
like relax I'll be home in an hour I'll
you know I'll take care of you we'll be
fine
so I was hoping
it was like this but then again when she
dropped the dog off I'm like that's
that's not good
and then you know I come my apartment
and um
and you know I found her in this bad
bedroom oh how'd she do it pills and
booze
and you found her where was she laying
in bed laying on the floor on the floor
yeah face down
face up this is something you never like
I had to give my grandmother CPR and
[ __ ] and then she passed away it's just
something that'll that'll never haunt
you of that image I can I could trace it
you know what I mean like I know you
know that position and that that still
is burned in your [ __ ] brain my dad
died of a heart attack in front of all
of us one Saturday morning we would have
trying to give him cprm stands watching
how old are you I was 28 at the time and
you're watching them die in front of you
yeah I mean my mom woke me up I did
something's wrong with your dad and we
all went upstairs and wait for the you
know the ambulance to come and all that
stuff you know they took him away and we
thought he was going to be okay and then
we go to the hospital I was like No And
I saw that
and then well what happened was it was
like a few years a few days before New
Year's I remember so
we were gonna go out for New Year's Eve
or something so I remember coming into
coming in the the apartment
and panicked and I ran into our bedroom
and she wasn't in there but I sawed a
dress on the bed that she picked out and
I looked there was a note on it and I
look at the note and she goes this is
the dress I won't be wearing on New
Year's Eve oh Jesus I'm like you got to
be [ __ ] kidding me should I go down
the hallway to our spare bedroom which
you know we just had a bed in there for
anyone to stay over and the door was
shut
and that's not normal not normal
and then I walked in and she was laying
there how long do you know how long she
had been dead I don't know did you try
to go over and see if she was still
breathing of course I
called 9-1-1 started giving him out to
mouth
you know they got over there pretty
quick
and they were like you know listen just
you know we're trying I thought maybe
she was I didn't know I felt no pulse
but I'm you know you still thinking
there's got to be she'll be all right
when it happened to me I was trying to
check my father's pulse but my heart was
racing so hard I couldn't [ __ ] tell
if I was getting a pulse or my heart was
about to explode you know what I mean
like there's so many things right that
you think it's gonna they're gonna be
fine my dad wasn't moving for a while
I'm like no it's gonna be fine they took
him away they put the oxygen I'm like
all right so he's gonna he's gonna live
this and then you get there like no it
was and they told us they go he died
right away he was not in pain like as
soon as it happened
you know but you when when that's going
on you know you're thinking all these
crazy thoughts right you know then all
of a sudden you know as this is going on
you know the cops come this and then all
of a sudden you're you're considered a
suspect right because they don't think
of that yeah you know what I mean I'm
the boyfriend but wait so you're you
call 9-1-1 and then the paramedics show
up yeah and are they treating her are
they like doing the clear yeah
I didn't want to go in there once they
came I go she's there I couldn't look I
couldn't
what I walked in was a nightmare so I
couldn't get back go back in there and
then the cops come are you crying at
this point or are you just shot on the
complete yeah at first I was but then
it's just like you're you're like what
yeah complete shock and then the cops
like whoa okay get out get out of the
apartment like wait in the hallway and
I'm like okay so they were questioning
me I'm like
and they're like okay we'll just want to
bring here you know the local police
station yeah when did it Dawn on you
like holy [ __ ] I'm a suspect you know
when my well my family showed up and
they're like my brother's a lawyer he's
like I go I think they they're gonna
have to question you like about what
he's like they're gonna have to question
I'm like holy [ __ ] so the cops like Hey
listen I'm gonna drive you guys family
wants to follow us back to the police
station I'm gonna drive with Jim we're
gonna go up there just ask we gotta fill
out a full you know uh a statement
and I'm like and I'm driving I'm like oh
my God is this
like because they always go to the
boyfriend they don't know they don't
know exactly what happened it was just
she was just laying there so it could
have been me or whatever so you're the
one who found her down there I call you
know and then you know they sat there
and talked to me and I said here here's
the voicemail yeah and the voicemail and
then she left a note she left notes for
me all around the apartment which I mean
more than one you know a goodbye note
you know they found that and then also
you know and then I played him the
voicemail said okay but you know I
didn't even know like I'm sitting there
with the two detectives and they're just
talking to me and about this what
happened I'm like man this could they
could be like listen man we're gonna
have to hold you I didn't even know
you're in such shock
you know ultimately like okay fine and
then they knew you know when I showed
them all that stuff but it was like and
then you know for the next month I think
the police are going to come to my house
because like you know am I a suspect but
then they said listen we found the notes
we obviously know she left them all over
the place and all that the voicemail so
that's a whole other level you got to
worry about
yeah I didn't even think of that that
you're being looked at for possible
murder yeah
it was brutal and you're going through
legit Trauma from the suicide and now
you got to worry about murder something
and yet I drive that a good police
station with a cop in the front seat
with them we're just talking you know
whatever like that I'm like
this is weird my dad my brother's like
hey man just you know tell them exactly
what happened of course I will
you know it was it was uh
it was rough man it was a financial
question what's that what'd you do with
the dress what'd you do with the notes I
still have the notes we have all of them
the last ones yeah you do yeah
once in a while I will
once in a while I will and it you know
it made me feel better because she's
like listen
um you gave me the best best six years
of my life and I would have done this
way before if I didn't meet you
so just know that you know that's
actually it's I mean that's Bittersweet
right there yeah she goes to just know
you gave me the best six years and it
I'm out of pain now I was in pain just
go live your life be happy
but you know when I read that it didn't
make sense to me because you're angry
right like why'd you do this to me you
think it's you know why'd you do it
why'd you make me yeah you knew I was
gonna find you you know what I mean I
had to walk in and you're you there's
all you've got a roller coaster emotions
you're sad obviously you're angry like
what the [ __ ] all this stuff I did for
you it still wasn't good enough
meanwhile I don't know anything about
depression and suicide I learned that
out later when I'm starting to heal you
know so and you and then and then you
know God forbid you smile five days
later or something makes you then you're
guilty because you're like how can I
laugh right how can I see you go shame
on me for feeling good right for feeling
good you you feel guilty about feeling
good you're like how can I do this when
this just happened all of this stuff I
mean it was it was horrible well so
you're also now the [ __ ] linchpin of
this whole thing so now you have to call
her brand new mom I mean not brand new
mom but the connection you just have to
call these people now and be like hey
she did that you're the one has to
notify everybody yep Jesus dude so who
do you have to call who do you calling
the adopted family oh yeah forgot about
them they got did they care what was
their reaction
um
they pretended they cared and then they
wanted all our stuff you know because
she had some you know designer bags
they really asked for that [ __ ] oh he's
[ __ ] I'm telling you man the vultures
when they come when someone dies and
people come out of the woodwork that's
when you find out who the real pieces of
[ __ ] in the family are absolutely the
vultures come out yeah they really do
get my my uncle took my father's camera
I'm like hey can I get a camera can I
get his camera like I don't even have a
dad can I get his camera he's like yeah
it's a good care Mama to keep it and
then you know then I just I'm you know
16 so I'm pissed off about something
dumb like a [ __ ] camera right it's
more about what this [ __ ] did but and
now they're [ __ ] cameras on phones
sometimes just gotta wait it out you
know something yeah you just gotta wait
to buy phone camera is better than my
dad's old camera I wouldn't be using
that [ __ ] anyway but I remember I
remember
um they were like there was you know my
it was we had a little dog one of those
little Yorkies like the Paris Hilton and
my girl used to always have it in a bag
a little dog bag and they were like
afterwards like that was a Louis Vuitton
bag where's that bag Memo's like a Hello
Kitty bag from the Hello Kitty store
it's like a ten dollar bag he sold that
we wanted he's stealing you know my
daughter's stuff you know that was a
designer she met the dog once like my
girl brought up that was Louis Vuitton
it was a 2500 dog bag we looked it up
where's that bag like all of the [ __ ]
all these accusations and stuff like
that I was in lawsuits with them
lawsuits they went that far with it well
because we also own the place together
we're both on the title to the condo so
now they won half years absolutely [ __ ]
that dude oh really they were coming for
Arrow coming to everything everything no
and there was a there was a thing and
then the agreement when we was you know
like if someone passed away usually you
sign it over to the person that's still
alive and we forgot to check that box
because we built agreed on that and go
Hey listen if something happens one of
us you know you got the place so you're
you're covered I'm covered and we've got
this so that I was in a lawsuit with
them for like two years but I never went
back after that day when I found there
in that place I told my mom I go listen
I can't go I can't walk back and then
I'd so you own that condo I know you had
to walk away from it I said I can't go
back in that nightmare where I walked
into I lived my mom for a year and a
half after that did you really yeah it
was like 41 years old at the time
something like that I mean man I said I
need to be taken care of because I would
go into therapy at the time because you
need to be taken care of go back with
your family
my sister live with her there was room
there and I'm like I need this I need to
be around family and friends I was
living like 45 minutes away yeah and I
can't be isolated in this place where
this happened I can't walk into this
every day and sleep there and forget it
I only went back one time when I sold
the place like two years later I walked
through and that was it and that was
even tough to do so it just sat for two
years three years because I was in a
whole thing with the ex with the family
you know so the lawsuits and all stuff
and then we ultimately sold it and they
had to [ __ ] off well I had to cut him a
nice check you did oh yeah because it
wasn't that chat that box wasn't checked
so according to law the other family
gets half so we had a fight back oh [ __ ]
dude I would I would have got I would
have [ __ ] gave him everything to just
get out of my life I hear you on that
you know I do hear you on that yeah this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual so when it's not working for
you it's normal to feel stuck therapists
are trained to help you figure out the
cause of challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
I'm a huge believer in therapy
um you know I it's great go work your
muscles out you need to do that but work
that mind out to work out everything
going on inside you it's awesome to talk
to someone and get it out and sometimes
you just need it you just need it okay
it helps as the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched three
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with the therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it couldn't be simpler
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 percent off your first
month at betterhelp.com
Honeydew that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew have you
started shopping for the holidays yet no
why not you know most gifts don't go bad
right right now you can shop early and
snag some of the best deals of the
season on something everyone will love
premium audio products from raycon when
you're looking for a gift everyone needs
raycons are the way to go their wireless
earbuds headphones and speakers offer
premium sound useful features and almost
custom comfortable fit and up to 54
hours of battery life as the person
gifting them you'll love that they start
at half the price of other premium audio
Brands plus raycon makes it easy with
holiday gift guides for everyone in your
life you can even knock that list out
all at once and get 30 percent off by
shopping raycon's holiday bundles
everyone needs a pair of raycons in
their ears whether it's for listening to
music taking work calls or catching the
Ravens game on the go you can find
raycon in stores now like Kohl's or
Walmart but let me tell you right now
you're always going to get the best deal
when you use my special link buy
raycon.com
honeydew right now go to byraycon.com
honeydew use the code early BF that's
e-a-r-l-y-b-f to get 20 off site-wide
that's 20 off any Raycom product which
almost never happens or save even bigger
and get 30 off for acon's exclusive
holiday bundles that's code
e-a-r-l-y-b-f at byraycon.com Honeydew
for twenty percent off your raycon
purchase buy raycon.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
what um all right well that was the
adopted families reaction how was her
mom and
very indifferent really did not blown
away or not blown away and not surprised
I didn't think you'd say that never
never came at a funeral no yep never
came really after they had just
connected they were on vacation so I was
like you know
can't let can't cut short to vacation
for their own child that they just
reconnected with who they [ __ ] real I
mean so now you know what it's the pain
that this girl was in the the craziness
she's been surrounded by [ __ ] surrounded
by show I mean you know they've still
got in a good relationship heard of mom
but for some I don't know maybe the mom
felt guilty who knows when it when it's
a suicide it's a whole other death it's
not cancer it's not a car accident
there's a million different questions a
million emotions you don't know how to
handle it so I I don't blame her for not
like I wasn't mad I'm like okay you're
not gonna call me like maybe she didn't
want to see the adopted mom all that
stuff so who knows what was going on who
knows the crazy pass so so do you have a
funeral you also in charge of all the
funeral [ __ ] too yeah God damn dude it's
all on you huh and it's funny because
she put in her note she goes whatever
you do don't bury me in that town where
my adopted family is from I don't want
to I don't want to be near them please
bury me near your family like in New
Jersey and I saw that in a note I didn't
want to tell the adopted family that I
was like can't tell him that because
we're still on good terms at the time
you know and I'm like I'm not going to
say it so today said hey can we bury her
in our town or the other family yeah
that's fine you know and then ultimately
did but then you know I should have and
then you know then they you know they
all of a sudden they where's the Louis
Vuitton bag where's all this [ __ ]
you know when it overcomes to items or
money or all that stuff so I never told
them that Ulta I should have but I was
like how am I going to tell this family
Hey listen by the way that she hated you
and she doesn't want to be so I just
love I go I'm not gonna tell him that so
she's buried in that town where she
don't want to be buried yeah I didn't
listen to him I didn't listen to him you
did a lot I know I know yeah
I'm sorry if she's mad but you know I'm
mad too because I gotta [ __ ] deal
with this now so no we'll just I go now
I can't do that that I family yeah but
then we're in litigation right now it's
like you should have when we litigate I
told the brother he was called me
yelling at me I go yeah well I'm going
to read you right from her no you know I
don't want to be buried near them but
you know whatever so he's like well yeah
she didn't write that okay yeah whatever
so so they didn't really know how much
she disliked them the adopted family I
think they kind of knew but you know
they pretended like everything was fine
but they wanted a couple hundred dollar
bag or I mean imagine that out of
everything I had the same thing happen
to me my grandmother dies my dad had
already died we have an uncle and his
wife and his kids come in they shut her
door they lock it my grandmother's
sisters are beating on the door like
they want they want some keepsakes and
they're like nope they [ __ ] took it
all in trash bags drug it down the steps
and went right out of the house and
we're like we're all sitting here
mourning the death of this woman I had
to give her CPR you know it's [ __ ] up
and here you are coming for jewelry and
whatever else so I remember she had this
one fake it was like a little CZ ring
you know cubic and um I found it and I
purposely took it down to my cousin's
house they had like a little cookout or
something I went there and I was like
look at this [ __ ] I found a grant and
they were like give it to me they came
snatching me I was like oh no yeah I
mean it was worth like twenty dollars
right but it looked like it was worth
twenty thousand you know what I mean and
they were like trying to get it and
everything else and I was like nah I've
never talked to those people ever again
yeah it's amazing how they come out of
woodwork you know look at my family like
my grandmother died my mom died you know
we we just basically okay this is what
it is okay it has a little money you
have a good family yeah I remember my
grandmother died like you know she had a
lot of stuff and I I was like all right
listen I don't want an antique table
from 1954. I don't care about these 1960
Forks that are silvered or rare she had
a handicapped placard for her card it
never expired I go I want that because I
could park at concerts right in the
front yeah you can anywhere you're in a
handicap and I'm hanging tailgating
again when the band goes on and that's
the only time I use it I don't use it
when I go to the supermarket I
understand that but there's like 75 a
handicap right in the front of the venue
yeah that's the only time I pull it out
that's all I wanted I go they're like
that's it I gotta say it I don't care
about anything else and I still have it
to this day do you really oh yeah does
it still work it's still yeah because
it's like the life it never expires yeah
I've got I did it 10 times this summer
at the concert venue near my house I'm
right in front I'm in handicapped that's
the only time I pull it out only time I
know that's the most valuable thing
it's the best that saved you a lot of
money yeah I want to be upfront I'm not
you're right there I'm not a spoiled but
I just like to hang and I you know just
where we're gonna meet and yeah I hear
the band all right the bands on let's go
let's go in because you can hear it's an
outdoor value it's a pavilion yeah
that's all I want I still have and I
hide it like I think like a valet guy is
going to see it in my gloves yeah so I
locked my glove compartment I only give
them the other parts that I can't get in
sometimes I'll stick it under the spare
tire in the back in my trunk because I'm
so petrified that someone's gonna take
that I love that that that's the key
that's all I want it's also it keeps it
is a Keepsake I'm like Thank you Grandma
I mean I mean I'm in front row again
thank you I can walk right in Thank you
Grandma
that's definitely a way to keep someone
I cheated a lot I know you just shaking
her head like of course of course that's
what you would do
oh
all right so
you mentioned um you needed to be taken
care of all right so we have funeral
everything happens and now you go right
to living with your mom and you do you
start therapy right away does someone
suggested or are you just like I [ __ ]
need to talk to somebody right away I go
online I start reading about suicide I
realize you know it's a lifelong of pain
and in that moment they just want to be
out I'm gonna interrupt you one second
sorry how old was she when she finally
passed 30. man that's a [ __ ] baby 30
years old babies Christ sorry go ahead
yeah start looking everything up
and it's you know in that moment when
someone's thinking about doing that
they're only thinking of being out of
pain they can't see any other way out of
whatever situation I'm thinking Jim's
going to be devastated by this all these
people they feel like they're a burden
if I'm gone I'm a burden people are
going to be happy oh thank God she was a
pain in the ass that's how people are
suicidal think because people have
um you know unsuccessfully tried I've
said in that moment I just want to be
out of pain I didn't care who found me I
didn't care about anyone else they're
going to be better off without me they
always think they're going to be better
off without me yeah I just was talking
to someone we watched I saw that um
a documentary about the guy that jumped
off the Golden Gate Bridge yeah and he
lived yeah and he said as soon as his
foot left he regretted it immediately
and he ended up just being a lucky one
because I think there's only a few that
have lived from that fall that fall
alone will kill you yeah yeah it's like
I you hit like cement but that high up
when you hit the water yeah and I had a
friend of mine
um he was a I was really close to his
brother but he was his younger brother
and we were all tight and he hung
himself and the thing that still sticks
in my mind is that they said they found
fingernail marks on his neck like he he
he had hung himself so when he jumped he
didn't realize right then I don't want
to [ __ ] do this but he had done it so
well he couldn't [ __ ] save himself
and he died hanging with marks on his
neck and that's what I think about all
the time like that guy didn't really
want to [ __ ] go no because you and
you know sometimes when it happens
someone loses a job or they're going
over off a breakup or they got you know
they have to file bankruptcy and like
it's and then to us it's like all right
that's a setback in our life but we'll
figure it out Panem it's there's no they
can't see any other way out of it right
so that when that moment that's all
they're thinking about is being I'm
doing everyone a favor here I'm doing
everybody a favor I did people gonna be
happy that I'm gone and not a burden
anymore and that's what they think so I
start looking up I'm learning about it
and I found these support groups
survivors of suicide it was almost like
an AAA meeting okay so it's at the local
hospital right down the street every
Tuesday night so I start going in them
right away for you dude I had to because
like you know I never dealt my father's
death at 28.
I didn't deal with it right away I was
in shock you know obviously I you know
it was mourning but I never really felt
it because it was just like I don't know
I was in my 20s I just you know was an
idiot back then I didn't yeah I cared
about I was doing stand-up at the time
three years in my career four year
whatever that's all I wanted I mean I
obviously I took some time off but I
never dealt when I said this thing could
Linger on forever if I don't deal with
it right now so I need to take this
thing head on so I was going right down
there every week every Tuesday a nice
Community we're talking to each other on
the phone and sitting in here hearing
everyone's story and what was good
because you would see someone that would
come in at the their son did it three
years ago and she we talked about it the
three years my son did and I'm like wow
and they they look like they were okay
I'm like I know I can get to that point
you know someone nine months I'm only a
month in someone nine months is feeling
better
you know nine months ago my son just saw
my guard in eight months I could I could
actually because you don't think you
think you're never gonna feel better
right this is always going to be you're
going to feel like [ __ ] death the
rest of your life or what happened so
that helped a lot too just knowing that
they were ahead of me and what was going
to happen and eventually I'm gonna
slowly start healing
you know and then um you know and then I
probably like nine months after I used
to go on Howard Stern Show all the time
I know yeah
um and he had me in and we told the
story he knew her too because I bring
around the show and stuff like that so I
told the whole story basically and then
I heard I probably got a hundred
different emails from people around the
country same thing happened to them they
didn't know how to deal with it I told
my thing so we had a whole community of
us just oh that's talking on the phone
yeah I'd go meet him when I come to town
and Phoenix or whatever let's go have
lunch they come to my show all that
stuff it helped me because I was about
nine months in and helped me to help
these people at two months ago this is
what's gonna happen you know whatever or
just happening I never dealt with it I'm
like this is what you should do go to a
support group meetings learn about it
you know a lot of stuff go on the
suicide walks whatever you know help
raise money awareness and all that you
know so that helped me just heal from it
too and then ultimately I just I knew I
really thought my career was over at
that point because I remember because
for like six months I couldn't come up
with one joke
no I probably went back on tour maybe
two months after I'm like I gotta get I
you know it's a comic you got to get on
stage that's my life I got I don't know
anything else
so but I couldn't come up with any
material at all I wasn't gonna talk
about it was way too soon obviously and
I'm like it's a tough thing to talk
about but I just might have had writer's
block I'm like I'm going on the road
doing the greatest hits I'm like man I
don't you know am I ever gonna write
anything again and then ultimately to
floodgates I did a one-man show about
the whole thing it's called I'm your
savior oh you did yeah I filmed it and
it's out there whatever so I did a whole
one-man show with slideshow and talked
about the whole story and all that stuff
so that helped me get through it but I
can only do it about 20 times I did the
show
and because I couldn't every night after
I I was it was exhausting you're
reliving a suicide every night up there
on stage and I felt it every time and I
was like I gotta I can't I can't do this
anymore so I filmed it and then that was
it you know I just got it out there I
was hoping maybe it could help some
people understand it because no one
understands this
you know they just like I said they just
think okay you'll be fine cry for help
but it's not you know and when someone's
like that you got a friend like that you
really got to go back to their family
your family's got to go take care of
them you got to contact the family so
listen just like an alcoholic or a drug
addict you gotta go hey man I'm hanging
out with my friend he's doing drugs he's
gonna die you gotta you know just want
to let you know what's going on
so that's what people have to do and
then hopefully the family can you know
again whether a medication or you know a
facility they don't like to talk like
that and um I call it his mom and she um
she was like thank you so much and I and
he's I mean I don't know if he's fine
now but he's alive yeah you know what
I'm saying he's still here yeah I don't
know what torture he's going through or
not right you know but they can get out
of it you know they can working on it
and stuff like that through you know
therapy medication whatever you know
they can live a productive life you know
some people that did it and survived it
like man I can't believe I was in that
bed of a state like I would you know did
you um have any of those people come in
and talk during therapy someone who
actually tried to take their life and
and survived no no none of none of that
but I just would watch stuff online
about that stuff and just you know I
just want to learn everything about it
because I didn't know anything about
suicide what's the thing that from like
going to the group there but I think
it's awesome that you met strangers out
on the road and went to lunch with him
and I hear you it healed you too yeah or
helped heal YouTube but um what's the
thing that stands out from those
about suicide like what's
what do you remember most about those
they would like to get to saying it
because you're saying [ __ ] like people's
my son
I'm five months in and I'm getting a
little better and all of a sudden this
new woman comes in she goes my 18 year
old son just committed suicide four days
ago and I'm like it's [ __ ] it was so
heavy man I was like I I stopped going
after about six months I couldn't take
it anymore it was so [ __ ] devastating
new people coming it never ends never
ends
you know when you see this mother just
falling apart telling her story because
that's it's almost like an Amy and he
tell your story it's going to be better
if you talk about it and everyone's
comments on it or whatever like that
it's you know so it was like oh man this
is so about six months but basically
they said it's a temporary I forget what
this word that the phrase is it's a
temporary solution to a permanent
problem it's just temporary it's gonna
go away
you know so it's just like but in that
moment that's that's all they cared
about right you know and it's just what
they're going through torture that
they're going through
you know look some people aren't made
for this Earth they're just not you know
what I mean it's just too painful for
them and I get that you know but it's
like it affects everybody around them
everybody that knew them and they they
really don't think it does
you know and that's that that's the hard
part to understand it's a weird death
you know and it's like you know you
gotta get a point where like no she
didn't do it because she was mad at you
you know because you were with whatever
it was just that Genie that was it it
was a like I remember going to a
therapist he goes listen
chapter three was the root of the
problem you were chapter three in our
life remember this chapter one was the
root of problem you weren't there for
chapter one and that that really made
sense I always remembered that I was
chapter three I came along in her life
at you know mid-20s I gave her happiness
right and I wasn't there in the
beginning when that all this [ __ ]
started you know in chapter one of our
life
so that helps that really helps like
okay so it wasn't you know I'm not the
problem right she she was feeling like
this from from day one right you know so
so here you are you're a good dude man
here you are going to [ __ ] therapy to
help yourself to figure all this out for
six months and this [ __ ] family that
raised this girl's wanting bags in her
condo [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
um well I said yeah and that's a whole
other level you know now you got to deal
with that right yeah
two years of non-stop so let me ask you
this then in that two years you're also
a [ __ ] man who needs some love when
when do you start dating
about eight months eight months and it
was fun weird because I was talking
about Howard Stern I go on the show
and I tell my story and then we go to
break like holy [ __ ] we come back and
then how it's like hey Robin Quivers to
psychic hey Jim single you're single
right because she just got a
relationship all right you went out with
Robin and that's what that's she's a
Baltimore I'm Baltimore she's a
Baltimore yeah yeah absolutely so
already Lang's there already Langs my
buddy he's the sidekick now it
completely changes we're busting balls
hey Jim will go see go you can go see
Ozzy with Jim you can wear you know
whatever like you know I'm just a heavy
metal dude white trash dude from Jersey
you know and um and they're like yeah
whatever like come on why you're single
he's singing why not go on a date and
then at one point she goes okay yeah go
come on I'll take you to freaking you
know I'm just making jokes your pull
play and whatever you hang on my Dirtbag
friends watch football on Sunday gamble
all right fine I'll go out with you I'll
go on a date with ya and I'm like holy
[ __ ] really
I'm like all right yeah let's do it and
then we went up dating for I don't know
like eight months after that that's how
we're friends first it was great because
I think at that point in my life and I
think maybe she did she just kind of a
long relationship I think we just needed
companionship I needed a companion
you know and we just go go meet and we
just we were friends for a while
you know and ultimately you know as a
comment were you able to stay friends
after you guys stopped seeing each other
um a little bit family friendly I was on
the show a few more times I think we're
still good but you know you know you
never really
stay super friendly with an ex but
ultimately you know look I'm a comic
you're a comic you just I every weekend
I'm working I can't and she works during
the week you know gets up at 4 30 and
more hours or crazy crazy and then on my
weekend that's when they have off it's
from day one I had a great girlfriend I
probably should have married when I
first started doing comedy and she's
like I want you around I'm like I can't
that's when I work
so ultimately that ended the
relationship because I was still like I
still want to do the Funny Bone in St
Louis I'm sorry I still I still I'm not
gonna just stop and I understand and I
can't see you during the week if I did
you know she'd have to go to bed early
we get the so it was it was I knew it
was going to come to a head at some
point because of that and she was
getting frustrated and I I get it you
know this lifestyle isn't for for
everyone no it's not yeah
and so how was it how was it having
companionship I mean that's also
different too because you're going from
you know an unknown regular civilian to
[ __ ] Robin quiver no I know and
that's when they have I mean that's
jumping in the deep end and they had
like the Howard Stern uh news crew the
news whatever following you around so
they were like one of the guys like all
right if you see Robin and Jim together
call this hotline so then people are
calling in [ __ ] oh yeah so they can't go
to dinner but one time one time I had to
take her to Applebee's
because no one would look for you there
no no because we're like down like the
Jersey Shore in the wintertime it's like
empty and that place is open I go listen
I go yeah the fine let's just go there
of course we get spotted in there Monday
morning on the show first Jim took it
Applebee's Robin come on you guys
you deserve better than that I'm
sleeping I'm getting all these messages
like come on he's got to do better than
that and then I they call me on the air
I'm like it's the only place it's the
only place open your gym Applebee's you
know who you're dating she's got class
it's not like you I go I know but I
didn't know and but Mew their spies
everywhere so everywhere we went oh he
saw Robin and Jim they were here they
were here they were at the movie all
that stuff so and I'm not like that I'm
a low-key guy yeah that's why I never
moved to Hollywood I don't I don't want
to hang out with celebrities I don't
give a [ __ ] I've hung one before it's
not that much fun so I'm not that guy at
all so all of a sudden I was getting
spawned like this sucks I don't want to
be freaking Paparazzi or just you know
fans going there they were here a
hotline all that [ __ ] so
um but you know what it was really I
think we both needed each other at that
point in our lives I think she needed
companionship to get over here you were
going through she sat there and listened
to you tell the whole [ __ ] story she
did she had no yeah exactly and I I
needed that at the time and ultimately
that's an interesting thing I feel like
even though
it only lasted what it lasted and why it
lasted but you're right you know here's
you don't have to tell the story at all
this is a woman coming in knowing
exactly what the [ __ ] you've been going
through for the last two [ __ ] years
with it yeah yeah or eight months excuse
me right and you know she knew me from
the show because I would sit in all the
time so you know she knew you well like
this stranger I'm gonna just say that
guy looks like a good dude right you got
to tell her this story right so uh but I
really think I did like looking back it
was a perfect time for us you know it
was a little moment in time
you know but I think we both needed each
other at that point we all know the
system isn't working thanks to crowd
Health we can do something about it open
enrollment is here and that means now is
the time to take charge of your health
care decisions crowd Health has a better
way to fund your health care costs see
any doctor you want no deductibles
exclusions or co-pays only pay the first
five hundred dollars of any health care
event the crowd Health Community takes
care of the rest no exclusive doctor
networks no huge premiums or high
deductibles no surprises your monthly
subscription helps fund health care
costs of the entire crowd Health
Community crowd Health provides true
peace of mind something insurance
companies don't seem to care about and
unlike insurance companies crowd Health
helps you find great care at a fair
price always pays doctors as quickly as
possible and actively negotiates to keep
costs down for everyone take charge of
your health care today with crowd Health
open enrollment is the only time you can
hit eject on on the broken system
without penalty so don't wait and for a
limited time join for just 99 a month
for your first six months when you use
promo code honeydew at join
crowdhealth.com that's join
crowdhealth.com promo code honeydew
crowd health is not health insurance
it's a totally different way of paying
for Health Care terms and conditions
apply you've probably heard by now that
you should be using a VPN when you
connect to the internet if you knew how
easy it is to protect your connection
with expressvpn you'd be doing it
already
expressvpn is the easiest way to browse
safely securely and just better first of
all it's blazing fast lots of other vpns
slow your connection but expressvpn
doesn't lag or buffer you can stream in
high def with no issues and using it
couldn't be easier just open the
expressvpn app click one button and
enjoy instant protection across all your
devices the fact is once you connect to
expressvpn you don't even realize you
have it on but your connection is secure
or your data is encrypted and you can
spoof your location so you can have
access to content available outside your
region no wonder it's been called the
best VPN by CNET right now go to
expressvpn.com honeydew and you can get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free that's
expressvpn.com honeydew to get three
extra months of expressvpn
expressvpn.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
and if you dealt with um any other
suicide in your life no no she's the
only one she's the only one yeah
go ahead but you know I died like I took
a course on it so I know like you really
dove into it huh it was an online course
come on still yes most people just go
about their phone they do it because I
was like hey man if I just had a friend
a good friend she just posted something
on Twitter the other day I'm friends
with her and her dad and she's like I
juice is in a facility I wound up trying
to kill myself whenever I'm feeling
better I was away for a month and I just
we just talked on the phone yesterday
and I called her she's like oh my God
out of blue I don't know her that well
you know and I'm like are you okay can
we talk and we talk to the phone and
stuff like that check that me I'm like
yeah because you need that you know but
you can't say to somebody that's you
know you people gonna miss you why would
you do that
come on you know that's the worst thing
because they don't they don't understand
that that doesn't make sense to them
when you say that because they love you
fuel them to want to do it more no I
don't think so setting them or they just
can't relate that language just doesn't
doesn't commute it doesn't connect you
need to go I understand where you're
coming from I I I I get why you're
thinking about committing suicide I I
totally get it
because that makes them like somebody
somebody gets me somebody understands I
I get where you're coming from I don't
blame you for thinking that absolutely
what you've been through then how do you
flip the butt let's let's get you help
you know what I mean don't be
embarrassed it's okay it's a depression
is a disease just like cancer and
diabetes you think like ah get over it
but it's a disease I didn't know that
either I'm like what are you depressed
about come on you got a great life you
know but it is a disease and people
don't realize that either
so I'm like you know go let's go let's
contact your family let's get you some
help why not don't be embarrassed this
is okay you know you have to talk to
them like that then like wow somebody
knows what I'm talking about what I'm
going through that's a big thing instead
of you people are gonna miss you why
would you do that to your family just
making them feel like they're not alone
and that you understand yeah you
understand where they're coming from
that's a big thing like that's how you
handle it not the other way which you do
which is logic goes why would you do
that you're gonna find a new boyfriend
you're gonna find a new wife
and in a year from now you're going to
be like with somebody else this is
amazing you know what I mean like but
they don't see it at that moment I was
telling my my nephew at his first crush
on this girl that you know didn't want
him he's 21 years old they go dude you
know how many girls you're gonna meet in
your life I go this is you're going to
think back at this okay yeah that one
girl didn't want me you're gonna forget
that girl you're gonna forget that girl
you have 21 years old you're a good
looking kid you're in a band are you
kidding me God you're about to sleep oh
absolutely
what the [ __ ] don't worry about it you
gotta worry about STDs and babies that's
what you need to worry about yeah I
gotta watch what's gonna happen in your
life you go oh yeah I remember I laid
like that girl when I was younger but
he's like that he was devastated I go
dude I know it sucks you're gonna have
to go throw it get through it and then
and you'll get better at getting through
it too I told my son he's 12. he's like
he was he's going to sixth grade he's
like this girl for like three years in
school and he's like I asked her because
we're going to middle school like the
last day of fifth grade uh will you be
my girlfriend going to middle school and
she goes um I'd rather just be friends
she text him back and he was crying he
was upset
and I'm like Luke
listen I go first of all
you're going to be in sixth grade with
all your friends at lunch she goes all
eat lunch together okay do you want to
sit at the girl from the table with your
girlfriend and her girl and her
girlfriends or do you want to sit with
all the boys all your friends over there
messing around ah you're gonna be
looking over there going I want to be
that that's fun over there you want to
sit with your girlfriend because you're
gonna you think she's gonna let you sit
with them there's no [ __ ] ways I
didn't think about that I'm trying to
break it down though you want to be
fooling around [ __ ] throwing food
make cracking jokes yeah then also I go
listen this is what how life is ten
times you're gonna get the girl you want
and 10 times you're not
so this is the one time you got her oh
you didn't get her but there's gonna be
one you're gonna get then the other guy
then someone else is going to get it
that's just life so this time you didn't
get her
yeah I was just on uh where my mom's at
with Christina pachitzki and we were
talking about she had a uh someone wrote
in or emailed in about um he's a 23 year
old virgin and he has incredible anxiety
about not knowing how to please a woman
and she's like what advice would you
give him and I was like bro you're never
gonna please every woman you're not
gonna mat a thousand no you're gonna
[ __ ] yeah you'd be lucky if you're 50
on it yeah so my advice is dive head
first into that [ __ ] and figure it out
cause that's it some people are practice
people for it for you as you get younger
I mean as you get older you know some
relationships for both parties are
practice they don't work out you learn
something from it you move on hopefully
you grow be a better person figure find
that partner you can work it all out
with that kind of [ __ ] but yeah you're
gonna [ __ ] up so much it's almost like a
baseball player if they three out of ten
that they bet 300 that's Hall of Fame
you're you're an All-Star you failed
seven out of ten you got the three I
always look at it it's a numbers game
that's it and listen you're gonna meet
some ladies who are like you don't know
how to [ __ ] give a hand job or you
know what I mean you're like no just get
out of here yeah they're not all gonna
buy a thousand for you either there's no
way yeah no I know but it's tough man
you know when you're growing up you're
awkward you're socially awkward you
don't know how to talk to girls uh
insecure I was all like that I always
grow up strict Catholic I was you know
I'm gonna go to hell if I masturbate if
I have sex all that stuff you know so I
had all that [ __ ] going on too in my
head
so I used to have sex with a girl when I
was young I would take my Jesus cross
off and stick it in my sneaker and throw
the sock in there so Jesus couldn't see
us having sex I felt so bad I'm like I'm
gonna burn again
I put the cross in first and then shove
the sock in just so we definitely
couldn't see through the sock through
the sock and the sneaker I swear to God
I was out of my [ __ ] mind that's what
that [ __ ] will do to you I was raised
Catholic too all the time like I can't
touch my own [ __ ] dick [ __ ] oh yeah
I'll burn in hell I used to think myself
all the time I'm burning hell for this
feeling right when the first time I did
it masturbating yeah no yeah how the
hell did you okay so I've talked to a
lot of guys that wait till later to
masturbate I just I don't want to say
discovered it like I had a lab coat on
but I I between the summer of fifth and
sixth grade I have two brothers
um I have a twin brother we're fraternal
he gets his own room that was my I got
the top I got the originally the top
bunk with my younger brother it was like
almost four years younger about three
and a half years younger
I'm just [ __ ] up there on that top
bunk just non-stop I found my dick and I
was so wait was your brother and the the
he's on the bottom bunk but but my mom
made the mistake of putting separating
the two of us like we're we're twins
we're at that same age where it's all
going on she's got me in the room with
my younger brother I'm up on that top
bunk jerking off every [ __ ] night
those are better guys every night he's
just always complaining that I'm up
there making noise or shaking the bed
and stuff and she put it together so
after we lived there one year after that
she put me in my brother my twin brother
back in a room together she's like y'all
are gonna go through this [ __ ] in your
own but did he know what you were doing
up there yeah I mean now we talk about
it but he didn't know he's like why are
you up there these beds are going like
he's probably I remember I used to be on
sometime in the bottom bunk and you put
your feet yeah shut up shut up wow you
did it in the room see I I like I said I
had the bathroom I did it everywhere I
had the bunks and then I had my brother
on the cot and down on the floor and I
was at the top bunk I'm like I can't I
got no privacy
yeah no I just get under the covers and
go for it yeah I was like but but the
thing I have learned because I only they
would talk to us about these wet dreams
we were gonna have these yeah they were
coming they were coming they were coming
well I only had like one or two my whole
life and what I learned later was I was
talking to Dr Drew about this like I was
releasing
my [ __ ] load right already because I
was jerking off so much so early yeah so
I didn't get a lot of them but I've
talked to I want to say it might have
been I I don't want to say I think it
was Adam Ray I'm gonna just say it if
I'm wrong Adam Ray I apologize but I
think it was him he was having wet
dreams like every [ __ ] he couldn't
even sleep over people's houses really
he was having them so often and I was
like were you masturbating he's like I
wasn't so his body was kicking it out
should have wore a condom in the bed
so did you have a lot of [ __ ] wet
dream I don't remember I I just know I
was curious if your body's just getting
that [ __ ] out of you all I know is I
remember the first time I had sex I was
like I had sex before I masturbated no I
was a month away from my 18th birthday
with my first girlfriend she we were
both virgins
and I had sex and I had the condom on
and I remember coming and I ran into the
bathroom like what the hell was that it
was the weirdest thing yeah because
you'd never come I never came before I'm
like oh my God and the condo was
completely full I mean but thank God I
didn't [ __ ] drown her
thank God it didn't burst open like a
damn first load of your load yeah I'm
about to wait for my 18th birthday
surprise she didn't take a raft home
and I was like what the hell is that oh
my God that's so weird a lot of that I
guess that would be [ __ ] weird I mean
I might have had a couple but I can't
remember so did a girl give you a hand
job before you gave yourself a hand job
yeah wow yeah that's interesting and I
remember I was 21 years old and I was
drunk one night I think probably like
making out with some girl whatever
nothing happened I was blue bald then I
remember in the middle of night drunk
masturbating like I didn't even have
anything they just started doing it
because I was you know I had a hard on
and I remember in the morning I felt so
guilty I'm like God damn what a loser I
am I remember I was DJing weddings at
the time everyone's gonna be looking at
me like what a loser can you believe
that guy did that I was [ __ ] that
depressed
yeah oh yeah but that like who's gonna
know yeah who the [ __ ] gonna know they
all do it they all do it I told the
story before in a podcast but it's a
true story so it takes me like three
days to get over it that I did that and
then I'm like you know what I'm already
going to hell God already saw me dude
even though it's under the covers and
then he can still see his little covers
he could still I go I went on a tear
I couldn't stop I swear within a week I
got bursitis in my arm my right arm I
swear to God so I'm playing softball I'm
like the star player and a softball team
it's the playoffs I go to the doctor
because I can't move it's freaking
killing me and he's like you you're
overusing that arm what are you doing I
go I I'm a lefty and I go yeah I play
baseball so he goes yeah whatever but I
had put my arm in a sling
because I had bursitis in my shoulder
right here how much were you sure
like an animal because I never use that
right arm for anything I'm a lefty so
all of a sudden I'm doing this and then
I remember showing up for the softball
field Saturday morning so I went like
Friday night cause I was in pain that
bursitis hurts and I show up in the
morning I go I can't play I got bursitis
in my arm my team was so mad at me
because I had my arm in a sling for like
four days of touching yourself from yeah
because I just like I'm already going to
hell so I might as well just keep doing
it I'm done
did you guys lose that playoffs yeah I
couldn't tell them why I go I don't know
what happened I couldn't tell me I just
started jerking off you know
they didn't get 21. yeah like I show up
I remember Saturday morning we're all
ready I'm like dude I can't
I couldn't even pinch hit
uh dude it's so good man that's so good
all right I I want to uh we're gonna get
you out of here but I wanna first of all
thank you for talking about this and if
anyone out there is struggling please
get help
um is I I want to say there's a new
isn't there a new suicide number
um
988 I feel like there's a new number
it's I don't know what it is it's like a
9-1-1 but not that right it's an easier
and that's a that's a good thing to talk
to somebody because those are those
people are trained to talk to you over
the phone on what to say like I was
saying before and all that stuff like
don't do it all that stuff sort of you
know yeah I mean look people are in
despair especially with the social media
man you get you know everybody's
bragging about what they're doing some
guy's sitting at home going man everyone
else's having fun I'm not meanwhile you
know well that's what this show is all
about that that I want to look right
here that's [ __ ] it's everyone's
Sports Center our our social media is
everyone's highlights and that's why I'm
saying like that's not what really is
going on in everyone's like one hour
that's why I like to sit right here and
talk about what's really going on in
people's lives nobody's putting a
[ __ ] suicide thing on goddamn idea
you know what I mean like we're good no
no because it's showing the one hour of
fun to have in a day they don't show
them when they're doing the dishes or
freaking just you know doing we're
struggling with someone who's suicidal
in their home or right a partner that
that just died or any of it yeah so then
so then these people at home and look at
wow look at everyone else having fun I'm
a loser I'm not having any fun everybody
out they didn't invite me how come
they're at the show how come they didn't
invite me I'm home and because they see
all that [ __ ] so that wears on people
too
you know so it's we're not in a good
spot but if people I really think that
like they should teach this [ __ ] in
school you know suicide forget the
stupid math that you're never gonna use
breathe you know what I mean I learned
how to write a check we don't even use
checks exactly yeah that's the one thing
I remember from from school I had to
write a check yeah you put the memo
what's it for yeah yeah I remember yeah
help people help people I mean it really
you know
so this episode is going to help a lot
of people this is a great episode thank
you I know this is not easy to talk
about yeah no I know but I just uh you
know I figured yep it can help somebody
why not I went through it I got to the
other side still you're gonna get 16
years later it's still it still haunts
me that's yeah but you know it's like
you got some point you gotta you know
never dream about her yeah you do yeah
what sort of dreams do you have is she
talking is she happy yeah yeah she's
talking she's happy you know you see her
we're going to concerts we go to
concerts a lot so yeah I still have the
dreams about her yeah where do you park
in those [ __ ] dreams at the concert
front row all right I want to ask you um
after what we've talked about now advice
you'd give to your 16 year old self
stop trying to save people you can't
save people you're not God
you could do your best that's it if
someone's damaged they're going to be
damaged you can try to help them but
you're not ultimately going to save them
and that that's not your burden or
responsibility you could be that form as
a friend and all that stuff but you're
not you're not going to fix it you know
there's damage that was done from the
childhood that needs to be repaired
whether to one chapter one through
therapy or something like that so don't
think you're just gonna and keep it's
it's wearing you know what I mean if
someone if you see that it's like you
know what that person's not right for me
I don't I don't I can't have that in my
life that's not my responsibility even
though it sounds mean I gotta find
someone that's more grounded that where
I could have a good life because it's
very stressful living with someone like
that so just don't think you could save
people because you can't you could try
to help them and that's it that's all
you could do but don't think you're
gonna be the Savior coming in and all of
a sudden they're going to be better
because you know what you're doing
because you don't
as the this is great I really
appreciated uh sitting here listening to
you yeah man no problem yeah plug it
away again everything please I got a
podcast everybody is awful wherever you
get podcasts my new comedy special bite
the bullets on Amazon Prime and then I
got a new prank call CD terrorizing
telemarket because I mess with
telemarketers I'm on volume seven I've
been doing it for 20 years I've never
grown up so if you like prank calls or I
and I turn the tables on the
telemarketers it's out there wherever
you listen to uh music thank you brother
thanks I appreciate that as always
ryansickler.com Ryan sickler on all
social media we'll talk to y'all next
week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]